JJ's in Rockford Illinois hey JJ welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave it's an
honor to speak you sir you too how can I
help
well sir I've been married for 20 years
and my wife I had been separated for
three and as you say most of it is all
because of money most marriages because
of money so this is the third time that
my wife and her spending habits have got
us greatly into debt so that's the
reason why we've been separated for
three years and trying to get it to work
out between her and I all boils down to
us not being on the same page and at
this point this is where I'm stuck I was
introduced to you three weeks ago
through a small group at church and as I
have watched 30 hours of you on YouTube
over the last three weeks there's a lot
of stuff you say that mentioned I have a
thousand dollars already saved I I in
the past have always snow balled my own
bills to pay him off and as I pay my
bills off she hands me a new stack of
bills so this is where I'm at the
divorce or not to divorce part and also
I want to know a little bit about 401 K
I am obviously in debt to my eyeballs my
total debt is approximately $50,000 that
is with the house our credit cards are
and what is your what is your income my
net income is 565 dollars a week that's
your take-home pay as to my take-home
pay is yeah I'm immediately take home
twenty-nine thousand three hundred
eighty dollars you okay so you're making
about thirty seven thirty eight thousand
bucks what does she make every time I
asked she says I don't know I know she
is a gas station manager and a waitress
she works two jobs I work two jobs my
second job is a cash job and I only make
a couple of thousand dollars a year I I
would I would say she probably makes
roughly what I make
she also has seventy three thousand four
hundred dollars in student loans with no
degree she owes five grand on a car she
lives in our own place we're separated -
she lives in her own place she she pays
$600 a month in rent okay are you guys
seeing a marriage counselor we've seen
one about ten years ago and when I asked
I asked if you are seeing a marriage
counselor are Li okay so why why is
there hope that the two of you are gonna
work this out if you're standing over
here throwing rocks at her and that is
your plan right now for getting back
together well I never really looked at
it as I was throwing rocks I just didn't
last five minutes I'm not sure she
didn't need rocks thrown at her but
you've been throwing them out over the
last five minutes while we're talking
yes I mean that there's no there's no
meeting of the minds there's no
reconciliation there's no game plan
where we get on the same page with
unless you've got some help doing that I
mean you've been separated for three
years you guys need to start working and
saving this thing or call it okay
marriage counselor right now number one
number one call your pastor said pastor
we need to sit down and if she will sit
down with you then the two of you start
working towards having a game plan
together now the way that you the way
that a healthy quality marriage works
around the money issue is there is no
yours in mine it's all ours when you got
married the preacher said and now you
are one he didn't pronounce you a
joint-venture and so she's gonna put all
of her income in the middle of the table
you're gonna put all of your income in
the middle of the table she's gonna put
all of her debt in the middle of the
table you're gonna put all your debt in
the middle of the table and for richer
for poorer in sickness and in health
until death do us part
we're going to use that pile of income
to attack that set of debts and we're
both going to be adults and talk about
every single thing that happens with
money before it leaves on paper that's
called a budget that we both agreed to
and then we both agree to stick to it
that's how a quality marriage with
cooperation and commune
occasion deals with the issues you put
in front of me and that's what good
marriage counseling will lead you guys
into doing so I I think she's
misbehaving I agree with you but I think
you guys are not working towards putting
everything on the same page and if
you're not gonna do that then you're not
married anymore I mean you just got you
talk that through with your pastor you
know but you need to sit down with a
good marriage counselor and say hey how
can we get on the same page aiming at
the same thing it's not you telling her
what to do is we're gonna put it all in
the middle of the table and the two of
us together are gonna grab hands and
we're gonna decide how we're gonna
handle every one of these dollars this
month and next month and next month and
what are our goals and how are we gonna
hit them hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]